third glass tonight put it on my tab you
drinking to remember forget giving a
[ __ ] won't get you a better tip can't
help highway my whole family was killed
in a car accident
someone did horrific experiments on me
you know this super vigilante [ __ ] keeps
coming at me
do you know Captain America
I want to absorb alias investigations
you don't want me you just want to
eliminate the competition
I never take no for an answer how rapey
of you something happened behind these
doors I have 17 years of questions and
they are deep just knowing what was done
to you might help you we were made here
me and something else
the only way to find it is to open the
door wider
[Music]
the powers were side-effect
how many others are there like me
let it go there is a killer you cannot
control I didn't ask for any of this
Jessica might not want a sidekick but
she needs one you're not super taking
time off keep telling me who are you
how dare you
what a face it makes me worse what are
you gonna do I don't know it depends on
if I can get through this night without
losing my [ __ ]
[Music]
today it takes a monster
to stop a monster
what did they do to us
you